cnbc story
cnbc story want to raise the kids with
high self-esteem a parenting expert on
the power of teaching your kids
repetition and ritual
the first few years of parenthood is a
huge adjustment especially if you're a
working parent
all of a sudden your baby is walking and
talking they turn then they turn three
and demanding to know why you have to
leave them to go to work
whatever your work schedule these
mornings those mornings evenings
weekends can feel
very short and you want to make them
enjoyable and high impact and building
your kids confidence and self-esteem the
key technique to getting there
is through teaching repetition and
ritual if your son knows you'll pick him
up and hug him in the same way when you
came through the door
each evening he'll look forward to it
and he'll be thrilled when it happens
sing that favorite song together each
day
on the way home from daycare begin each
saturday morning with breakfast at the
same time
tuck him into bed in a consistent way
each night for you repetition is dull
but for children
especially toddlers it's wonderful and
reassuring the world is a brand new and
complex place
and when they see patterns in in it or
accurately spot what's coming next it
gives them a sense of security mastery
and delight
tom uh i i think there's some truth in
this but i think it was a puff piece by
cnbc
but i will say this you know what you do
when you bring consistency to a
two-year-old
they sleep through the night and
everybody's happy yeah so
when you you put them to bed at the same
time and put them through a ritual
they yeah they the kid has a more
consistent pattern you don't want the
kid waking up middle of night crawling
into bed
with the toy saying it's time to play
that's no it's not it's 4 a.m leave his
lawn
the obviously that's never happened to
you oh it's happened to everybody where
your kids had a sink you're at a
you know you go out of town to a wedding
and so you're up late till 10 o'clock
and then the kids had a sink
and then the next two days the kids
literally out of sync they're tired
they're grumpy it's hard to get them up
and so when you take the routine of it i
think routine for kids is good
it gets sleep patterns and activity
patterns
but i'll tell you i'll tell you
something else there is something here
in consistency and trust
because the kids want to trust in
something right it is a tough world out
there
and kids feel stressed in certain ways
too but when they
know that you're going to be there and
they can count on that
that is a huge part of the parental
child love
i can count on you it also gives you
permission
and it gives you the opening to put the
disciplines around them the disciplines
of structure
behavior of time and things like that
i'll tell you if you travel with tom
here's what happens tom
every morning calls his daughters no
matter where he is in the world okay
and every night before he goes to sleep
tom calls his daughters and they pray
together
no matter when it is by the way i've
never seen tom forget those two things
when i tell you never i mean i've never
ever
ever we could be at a party tom will
step out make the call talk to his girls
and he'll come back into the party no
one knows what happened
but i'll see tom on the front of the
kind of what tom don't leave him alone
he'll be back in 20 minutes
does this thing comes back when i tell
you consistently
i mean consistently his daughter is
probably going to end up going to penn
okay if not michigan but she's going to
get to choose where she wants to go her
his oldest bailey who responded the
other day to scott galloway's article in
a way that
adults wouldn't respond to what uh
bailey said and then brooke is probably
going to be an mit student if she wanted
to she can go anywhere
a lot of it is how he and kim raise
their kids with the rituals adam
yourself
you hear this commentary do you have any
any thoughts that makes me think a
couple of things you brought up you know
the whole work life balance i know you
were kind of mocking that a little bit
but essentially what i i would take from
that is
rather than you having to get home at 5
30 and then
we kind of mockingly said yeah you're
spending two hours on the phone and
you're bs'ing
it seems like it's more important to
have one hour of quality time where you
guys can
you know throw the baseball or you know
do you know whatever you do with your
daughter play dress up whatever the hell
it is that is
special yeah i know you put on some some
pink outfits and you put on a crown and
a lot of
i've seen you do that yes with santa but
the point is it comes down to quality
time and repetition
and uh and just being there for your kid
like i gotta tell you
every time i get out of here at eight
o'clock i'm home right i'm home by 8 15.
my cats are getting that good quality
time y'all all right they get a good
hour of what
how's your day parents you are it's it's
it's repetition
you know and every weekend so every
weekend they know
to them or no do you talk to them at all
or no i talked to jimbo yeah
i see you have a great relationship like
as much as you we make fun of my cats
you got two dogs that are your
everything
oh my gosh i'm not listen if i can't my
way out of 10 cats at the house i love
cats i'm not uh
i'm part of the community of cat lovers
man i will say
for those who are dog guys cat guys i've
seen some cats before that suck
i would never raise my cats to be sucky
like this is it based on the parent or
based on the 100
based on the parent and if you're gonna
get a cat there you go get two cats
because they're playing all day
joking around should we left out
fighting
economics yes how do you introduce keys
to raising cats yes right
nothing's worse than one solo so we have
to go back
20 minutes now we have to add to it how
do you judge people by
the behavior of their cats yeah that's a
very good point that's philosophical do
they have good cats
that's something like frederick are they
are they arrogant
i don't care about you and i'm just
gonna sit over here no i would never
raise cats like that you know what i'm
talking about
adam would slap him around oh yeah snap
out of it don't be cocky with me
no exactly so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody bye